how are you all that's why i'm doing a
little wellness check how's everybody
doing to their heads your hearts
everybody good
i appreciate a wellness check knowing
again i have to say
uh uh people don't do that enough i'm
good
i'm good i'm uh yeah my me and my family
are good that's
you know all i can sort of hope for and
the in the immediacy of life i guess and
uh
yeah we're we're in a good place anthony
how you doing
same here same here i'm stuck in uh
europe but
i'm good well i don't know if i would
say you're stuck in europe you're doing
something pretty good
there's no football i missed lebron
win the championship is
it's crawfish season i got all kind of
problems going on
i love it yes it is crawfish season
but you're a superhero though brother
you're a superhero
tap into that oh no
[Music]
it's time but anthony you're not stuck
in europe once again you're back on set
shooting falcon and winter soldier how's
it different from when you were there
coveted
and now you're back uh well everybody's
very afraid of each other uh the food is
bad
because they have to pack it up
somewhere else and bring it to us in
ziploc bags
um yeah it's
it's awful it's it's literally you're
living in quarantine it's not like the
nba bubble
where they had like a barbershop and
friends to hang out with no if you get
within
six feet of somebody there's some little
czech dude
coming poking you with a stick and
saying you have food
so it's um it's rough but you're making
my marvel heart
happy so i appreciate that i do i do
and can i just ask you because this is
the first time i've gotten to talk to
you since we lost chadwick just
you know maybe a a memory of him that
you'll never forget
um you know it's uh it's funny i have a
lot of memories of chad and
um i cared about him dearly as a friend
and uh the first time i met him um was
in 1998 i went down to howard and he was
directing a play there
and my girlfriend at the time um
brought me into the theater to check out
the elizabeth catholic collection
and he was in the black box in an office
chair spinning around the room
and she was like hey chad i want you to
meet my classmate juilliard anthony
and he goes wait i'm concentrating don't
break my vibe
he just spins around the room and i was
like
it's nice to meet you man like i'm
almost there
i'm almost there i love it
that actually that's an amazing story
that's a really really good memory
that's a very very good memory or he
would be cracking up laughing if you
told that story right now
all the time so and like
once everything kind of took off for him
i was like remember the first time we
met
he was like yeah i don't want to talk
about it i was going through a lot
in my young age
that's the best well you know what even
though this movie was hard to watch guys
i actually felt like it was a bit of a
love letter to new orleans and i
appreciate that because i know
you're from there anthony is your heart
i used to live there it's my heart
and so i just appreciated seeing new
orleans on screen
here here i agree by the way your
instagrams of you dressing up with your
little girls have
sent me to a place
becky with the blue hair just sent me to
a place
yeah this is going to be a theme today i
think to impress wow
yeah how quickly can i delete these
pictures so that uh
i don't don't you ever don't
that is my wellness check when i can
just log on and look at you there i mean
do they have to talk you into it was it
just like we don't have anything else to
do why not make dad look
documental he talked them into it
um you know like it's just a slightly
heightened version of what i
do for a living anyway so you know it's
kind of um
yeah it doesn't take a lot for me to
slip it there
so um so i'm watching this movie fellas
and i'm thinking to myself
could i ever work every single day with
like my
best friend for life i answer
i don't i don't think so i mean what do
you what are you all thinking um
and i'm gonna start with you could you
work every day
and especially in like a high stress
situation like that with your best
friend for life
well i think you would have to and i
think most relationships you look at
it you know your your best friend is
basically your second spouse
or sometimes your spouse is your second
spouse
yeah so you know there are things that
you share with your friend that you're
not comfortable sharing with your spouse
and vice versa
so you know being in that situation
spending that time
and the idea of the the contemporary
bromance
is very different you know if
you ask any dude he's out with his boys
and his girl called
you like yo don't say nothing she's
gonna know i'm having fun i'm going
outside
you know yeah so you you don't want to
leave that good time
yeah for sure what do you say jamie yeah
listen i
i i i don't think um
i sort of love i i think working with
anyone all the time
but like that it would be difficult in
any situation
best friend or not that's what i kind of
love about what we get to do for a
living that we have this whole new set
of
like players to play with every job
every tv show whatever it is that we do
um we get this whole new like family for
like three or four months
uh and it's this lovely thing where you
get to act like your best friends and
you are for that time and then
some people you stay in good touch with
some people you don't stay as good touch
but you get on great when you see them
it's great but
there's not that sort of um necessity to
like
always be with each other beyond what
you're trying to achieve for that one
movie or whatever you know so i kind of
like the way i couldn't do it all the
time
that explains why you don't text me back
i didn't want to say nothing but uh
one of the themes of this movie actually
one of the central theme of this movie i
think is
you know how we deal with the past and
do we romanticize it
do does it haunt us um kind of
you know where we fit in to that um i
try to feel like i'm a person that lives
in the present but i think i am a
dweller on the past what about you two
jamie what about you yeah i think it's
hard not to be i'm very nostalgic
person you know i uh i did i did a
workout today and i was working with
trainer and he was like
should we listen to like 90s hits i was
like
i mean i just had to sort of stop and
chat to him like after everything
there's nothing like 90s r b though
honey come on now
this was a lot of this was like some it
threw like a british
um but it was it was fun you know
i think like everyone isn't everyone
trying to live in the present at all
times and you know anthony and i both
have young kids and and that
that keeps you fairly present but um
outside of that
yeah it's very easy to to be thinking
back to like what you dean might have
been a
sort of better time for certain aspects
of your life or whatever it was so
um but you try not to do that too much i
don't think it's too healthy
yeah what about you anthony are you a
i'm here with you
or like i'm thinking about what happened
you know what i realized
this weekend my um my niece
we had a baby shower this weekend for my
niece at my house
and all of my siblings was there but i
wasn't there because i'm stuck in europe
so i had to like you know zoom in to see
the baby show and i realized i've spent
i left home when i was 16.
i've spent the last 25 years of my life
trying to make my sisters like me no
[Laughter]
and i want everybody to notice you know
my sisters
i've spent the last actually 25
30 20 30 years of my life since i was 10
years old
and i threw water balloons on my
sister's birthday party
i've been spending the rest of my life
trying to make my sisters like me
i realized this weekend that my sisters
like me which was monumental
but now they have daughters and my
nieces
hate me so now bullied by a
second generation so now i gotta spend
the next 20 years of my life trying to
get my nieces
to i just paid for a whole damn baby
shower that i wasn't at
you